Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. So I had a pretty big week last week. My novel The Fault in Our Stars returned to number 1 on the New York Times Bestseller List
56 weeks after it came out. Also,
my wife and I are expecting our second child,
whom the President of the United
States told not to forget to be awesome,
but most importantly Hank,
for the first time in American history, a sitting President of the United States
acknowledged that pennies are a terrible idea.
He also acknowledged the penny is an excellent metaphor for what's wrong with government,
so yeah, it was an incredible
week! And in the wake of incredible weeks,
what I usually do is crawl into bed.
I don't know why this is, Hank, but it's been happening my whole life. I just get overwhelmed with anxiety and
I decide I should crawl into bed and never do anything ever again
But that is a bad life strategy Hank, so today I'm going to update you on
12 things that we're doing.
1. 'mental_floss'. Hank, people often ask me how to get started as a writer. My advice is
always to find people who are also
starting out, and work with them. My first
writing gig ever in my life
was with 'mental_floss'. 10 years later, I'm talking to a camera for a living and
they've go on to become this educational and trivia empire, but they've never had a YouTube channel
until now! Hank, you and I are both working on this, and I'm really excited to bring 'mental_floss' to YouTube.
There's going to be list videos and quizzes, and like a cool intro, it's going to be great.
Thing 2 - The Project for Awesome. So Hank, we still haven't announced which charities are getting
the money,
but that's because we don't know how much money there is going to be,
and we probably won't know for a couple more weeks,
because we had to work with PayPal, and figure out how much shipping costs, and various other things.
Thing 3 - The Fault in Our Stars movie? I'm not gonna lie to you,
I've had my heart broken by Hollywood before, but I'm
starting to think that The Fault in Our Stars movie is
actually going to be a thing, so yeah.
That said, please don't believe
everything that you read on the internet,
because journalists who work in Los
Angeles seem to just make things up.
Rest assured, that when there is news, it will not come from, like, 'celebgossip.buzz', it will come from me.
Thing 4 - DFTBA Records. Having taken over an abandoned nursery school in Missoula, Montana,
DFTBA Records is bigger and more awesome than ever!
We're continuing to try to make DFTBA more and more about getting cool stuff that also supports people you like,
whether that's a CGP Grey coffee mug, or a Wheezy Waiter T-shirt,
or a poster partly designed by a 16 year-old Norwegian girl named Asseal.
Number 5 - My writing. I'm trying...
Number 6 - The Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers.
Hank, the last FIFA 11 Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers video goes up tomorrow, when we will find out if we win the Barclays premiere league,
and if the miracle of Swindon Town is complete! I just wanna go out and win it for the boys.
By the way Hank, the actual Swindon Town football club is currently looking for a manager,
and I just wanna state for the record - I am available!
Number SEVEN: CrashCourse! Hank, you've just started teaching chemistry, which sounds very unpromising and yet,
it has been really entertaining and interesting and I am kind of learning.
Meanwhile, I'm three episodes into teaching the history of Canada's pants, also known as the United States of America.
Number 8 - VidCon 2013. Hank, most of the tickets to VidCon 2013 are gone, so if people want one they should get one now.
VidCon's gonna be really fun this year. It will also be the first time that I leave the house after the birth of my kid so I will be ready to party.
And by party, I mean sleep for 8 hours in a row. You know what I'm talking about, parents!
Number 9 - "The Lizzy Bennet Diaries". Hank, I get several e-mails a day, complimenting me on my excellent work for "The Lizzie Bennet" diaries,
which I don't do; I am not involved in that project at all. However, I am happy to take credit for it!
Number 10 - The kiva.org nerdfighters! Hank, the nerdfighters of kiva are approaching TWO MILLION dollars in loans to entrepreneurs in the developing world!
Number 11 - Parenting is still my biggest job at the moment and Number 12 - 2D-GLASSES,
which render 3-dimensional movies into crisp 2-dimensions.
Hank, this idea that you had for 2-D glasses, which I thought was a terrible idea turns out to have been brilliant!
The '2-D glasses' Empire grows by the day. Hank, you have way too many ideas, but thank you for having them, because they pull me out of the quicksand of myself,
and force me to get to work. DFTBA, I will see you on Friday.